[Musique]
avec la famille le responsable des
programmes de france bleu orléans il est
avec nous jean luc vinet bonjour bonjour
c'est un gros coup se prépare tout le
mois de mars sur france bleu orléans
avec des concerts à domicile diffusé à
la radio
également en intégralité sur internet
comment est ce possible comment ça va
s'organiser
alors c'est comment c'est possible en
respectant les conditions sanitaires
ça c'était le mot d'ordre de débris
l'envy de départ c'était de se dire les
concerts qu'on ne peut plus y aller des
brouillons nous pourrons faire quand
même
donc le concert vient chez nos auditeurs
alors évidemment avec un public
restreint avec la public reste un plus
vieux canapé et cannelle en général les
trois personnes qui sont là dans le dans
le foyer avec des formations pour les
artistes aussi réduite
c'est en général l'artiste est un
musicien est le minimum de techniciens
aussi l'idée c'était de retrouver quand
même le plaisir du concert et le plaisir
a été au rendez vous déjà pour ceux qui
ont déjà été réalisés pour tout le monde
comme est meilleur pour tout le monde
air pur pour nous à l'organisation mais
pour les spectateurs même de nombreux
sens alors les artistes alors que ça a
été le le bonheur certes ils ont tous
fait des prestations diffusés sur les
réseaux sociaux et est belle prestation
mais il n'y avait pas la rencontre avec
les là où vous jouez un gros coup un
joli coup à france bleu c'est qu'en plus
les artistes ont rémunéré il faut le
dire ça on pouvait pas faire autrement
sincèrement leur demander une prestation
une réelle prestation de concert et ne
pas les rémunérer
ça c'était pas possible c'était pas
envisageable tout le mois de mars vous
rendez honneur sur france bleu orléans à
la femme
on le verra dans divers programmes mais
également au travers de tous ces
concerts parce qu'il y aura quatre
artistes féminines 4 styles de musique
différents
on commence par liz van deuq on la
qualifie souvent de funk et rock à la
fois pince sans rire aussi
en deux mots qu'est ce qui vous a séduit
chez elle lisons doc c'est celle à la
folie douce
verser ces politiques c'est extrêmement
travaillée c'est une pianiste et une
compositrice c'est vraiment quelqu'un de
très fins et qui cisèle tous y compris
ses textes et donc ça donne des des
choses légères en apparence parce que
sur le fond ça ne l'est pas du tout dans
les chrétiens dans les dames en daim
c'est ça et donc c'est c'est une artiste
qui nous emmène dans son monde
délicatement tranquillement mais un
monde
époustouflant la deuxième artiste on la
connaît bien puisque nous l'avions reçu
en plateau elle nous a même offert un
mini concert c'est anita farmine pour
ceux qui ne la connaissent pas jean-luc
que vous pouvez la décrire cette femme
incroyable solaire fallait avoir c'est
ça elle est vraiment solaire et puis on
associe souvent le mot de world music à
ce qu'elle fait mais c'est une
franco-iranienne qui est passé par
l'algérie et et et donc du coup dont
tous ses concerts il ya
du français il ya du persan il y a de
l'anglais et du coup il ya tous ces
mélanges qui vivent en même temps par
par sa force et de ses prestations céder
la world mx1 mais résolument moderne
corre ac c'est c'est une vraie artiste
d'aujourd'hui avec tous ces mélanges et
c'est important
les mélanges annonce était c'était aussi
magnifique et elle nous porte dans dans
un loukoum savoureux non c'est vrai on
combine solaire mais même dans
l'instrumentation sur le stream de
talent qui mélangée qui nous ont même
fait le voyage on continue dans le
bien-être
parce que la musique nous apporte ça
avec yves annie j'ai envie de dire c'est
un peu notre rihanna à la française mais
je dis pas ça au hasard parce qu'elle
s'est fait remarquer ya pas longtemps à
reprendre un titre de rinat skype home
va nommer le titre elle incarne de l'aca
au pop colorée elle incarne un truc qui
donne la pêche tout simplement on avait
besoin de de ce style là en ce moment en
fait en ce moment on a besoin de tous
les styles et c'était important sur
soeur sur ses concerts qu'il y ait tous
les styles et c'est vrai que livni cc7
ce côté joyeux c'est une ville exotique
c'est de la britpop
mais porté par une voix et est évident
qu'une femme plus puissante est qui et
qui peut se permettre de se promener
parce que vous citiez donc
il y en a mais janet jackson ou michael
jackson et des textes aussi en français
qui a décrit c'est vraiment une artiste
pardon de vous couper par jour comment
on accourt et on savourera sur france
bleu orléans tout le mois de mars
on termine avec votre cool quand l'heure
ça je le sais elle vous avez découvert
une perte dans un coquillage des bords
de loire
elle s'appelle les autres eléonore
qu'est-ce qui vous hypnotise chez elle
d'abord c'est parce que quand quand j'ai
reçu ce disque je me suis dit on la
connaît pas et donc l'idée première
était de se dire il faut absolument
qu'on la fasse découvrir les autres
commencent à avoir une certaine
notoriété dans la région eléonore pas du
tout eléonore on écoute son disque on
est mais envoûté par sa voix elle issue
avait les should he les f1 on entend
bien et entre le jazz le hip hop un peu
de soul elle est vraiment magnifique et
c'est tout ce mic cela qu'on aura su
tout mois de mars sur france bleu
orléans aller sur le site allez sur la
radio tout sera diffusée les concerts un
titre par semaine elles auront tous à
ces artistes
merci beaucoup et me dit merci jean luc
vinet